追加1な50枚これを吸ってさあもう
ええええええ
あー容量わかったぞ
i まぁ見てもらった感じになって薄くなければねもうかバカっていきます
市塩名田レバーをとしているものが付いてどういうのをよく見かけてその一員だまで誰
もキングカードを作って誰もう図書するとパパ角ばってすごいはずができるっていうを
見た
底でが考えたかこちらにジェンダーの試験前準備しました今日は今日は宴ジェンナー
1000枚でジェンヌざるマート数っていうと思います
なんかねそれっぽい動画見直し
700m 人もいたしもっとたくさん出てる人もいたけどもみんなちょっと失敗してた
重ねてやればいいじゃんみたいな人が多かったんですけども
俺はちゃんとフォン秘策がありますからで愛甲 pa 走行んで僕の作戦なんですけど
まぁぬーん
決定なはずやってたんですけども甘いぞこんなたくさん100万円でも寝ずに乗らない
ものを千枚普通に乗らせて寝るわけがないんですよそこで8日今回こちらの直90度
ですね90度の角度がある某用意しましたジャズこの棒の中にチェン弾を入れていき
ます御膳た方5選として言ってバーンとためジャパンと起き上がってすバンクられます
バンッ
ちょっとうまく説明できないんですけどとりあえず90度で善玉のそのズレを全部して
きれいに均等にした後にパッと立たせるという作戦です上手く説明できないけど見てれ
ば分かりました
ここにセダンはどんどん放り投げてセットしていきますこれでガンガンも以前のおいて
いけばよいですよねっ
何も支えはなくまっすぐ1円玉を手で建てるよりかはかなりキレイに
正確に確実に言ってんだこの塔が建てられると僕は思ったわけです
2分を切った
誰もやもういっぱいになっちゃうよだってことはないと全然たんないよ
悩まされてくださいそうてまいります
のパ
うんうんっ
tan
tue
はいと良い音何度か先輩全然乗りました
さぁみんなべきだ線ないでしょ1000枚ってことにしときましょう
まゆでここからです今こちらに丁寧に並べたらこの5名
マッチョませんません30000待って待って待って待って
あーざす5んっ ok
もうこんなまたてましょうサンキューみたいなピザを犯したくないんでこのまあこの
マウスパッド立ててもタワーを作ります
あの場所
ううーん本当にまあねこれで失敗すると思っちゃうのがお住まいですこれをちゃんと
立ててとりあえずタワーにすることがまずレベル1
そこまでしっかりこなしましょうはもう2回もミスというか本当にもブレず失敗許され
ないけどじゃあちょっとゆっくり食べていきましょう
ターンなることがまず第一条件多分はずなのよゆっくりでいいよ
池に買っていくとその勢いでかといっちゃうそのゆっくりで当てその勢いで買って言っ
ちゃうとも本当にさもいけるかって十分
me
e 4
3種
いいします
まだ大丈夫まだ島の大丈夫でしょ
ちょっと立てればいいんだろう
はぁそれぐらいでしょ
いいなん
th